bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui dans science clic les trous
noirs l'espace temps dans lequel nous
vivons peut être imaginé comme une
grille tout corp qui possède une masse
déforme l'espace-temps formant autour de
lui un puits gravitationnelle si un
autre objet se trouve à proximité
il va alors être attirés en descendant
le puits gravitationnelle comme une [ __ ]
ou man dans un bol plus la masse du
corps est importante plus la traction
devient forte est ainsi plus l'objet
attiré doit se déplacer rapidement pour
se libérer de l'attraction
gravitationnelle
or si la str devient assez massif tout
en gardant la même taille le plus
gravitationnelle engendré sera tellement
important que cette vitesse de
libération dépassera la vitesse de la
lumière
et comme rien ne peut se déplacer plus
rapidement que la lumière alors rien ne
pourra plus échapper de cette attraction
même la lumière en se rapprochant trop
près sera capturé
c'est un trou noir à la base un trou
noir renferme une singularité
gravitationnelle c'est à dire un point
de l'espace au niveau duquel la courbure
de l'espace temps devient infinie plus
on s'éloigne de cette singularité mois
l'attraction gravitationnelle est forte
et lorsque l'on arrive en dehors d'une
limite qu'on appelle l'horizon des
événements l'attraction devient assez
faible pour que la lumière passant à
proximité puissent échapper autre noir
ainsi tous ceux qui se trouvent en
dehors de l'horizon peut espérer
échapper au trou noir
mais dès qu'un objet dépasse l'horizon
alors il est destiné à tomber dans le
trou noir sans jamais pouvoir revenir en
arrière
comme les trous noirs engloutissent
toute lumière passant trop près ils nous
apparaissent noir et ne peuvent donc pas
être vu directement
cependant on peut les détecter de
manière indirecte
tout d'abord leur présence et trahis par
leur influence gravitationnelle très
forte
en effet étant capable de dévier la
lumière les trous noirs vont agir comme
des lentilles gravitationnelles qui vont
dévier la trajectoire des rayons
lumineux en provenance des toiles
lointaine créant ainsi des mirages
gravitationnelle ayant également une
forte influence à grande distance et
trous noirs peuvent également être
repéré en étudiant la trajectoire des
étoiles environnantes
enfin jack ury trou noir n'émettent pas
de rayonnement par eux mêmes ils en
émettent de façon indirecte en effet
autour de certains trous noirs la
matière environnante subissant la
traction former un disque en rotation
autour de la singularité
ce disque d'accrétion en tournant à des
vitesses très élevées va s'échauffer et
mettre des rayons x et gamma qui sont
relativement simples à détecter il
existe dans l'univers des trous noirs de
toutes les tailles les plus petit qu'on
appelle trous noirs stellaires résulte
de l'effondrement de certaines étoiles
massives grande seulement quelques
kilomètres
il représente plusieurs fois la masse du
soleil les plus grands trous noirs quant
à eux se situent généralement au centre
des galaxies comme la nôtre ces trous
noirs supermassifs sont très grands
pouvant atteindre plusieurs milliards de
kilomètres enfin bien que les trous
noirs ne puisse pas émettre de
rayonnement des effets quantiques
complexes font en sorte que chaque trou
noir s'évapore lentement en émettant un
rayonnement qu'on appelle rayonnement de
hawking plus un trou noir est grand plus
il va mettre longtemps à s'évaporer
ainsi pour les trous noirs de taille
normale cette évaporation est
extrêmement lente
s'étalant sur plusieurs milliards
d'années est donc très négligeable
cependant il pourrait également exister
des trous noirs microscopiques qui se
serait formé juste après le big bang
pour ces trous noirs primordiaux le
phénomène d'évaporation deviendrait
alors très importants entraînant une
disparition quasi instantanée les trous
noirs sont donc des objets complexes qui
regorge de mystères et qui alimente
l'imagination des scientifiques
ils ont donné naissance à beaucoup de
questions et d'hypothèses
comme par exemple l'existence de
raccourcis qui permettrait de se
déplacer dans l'espace temps les trous
de ver